Hey does this, Stephanie
Vandenberg does this. Ana,
we're going to play a game
and candid can fashion.
Um, uh, no, I am from Panama
and I moved to the lake,
become a special effects makeup artists
who have me, I'm Stephanie. Been Berg.
I am a fashion designer and I'm a mother.
I heard you guys met in a peculiar way.
Can you tell me the story of how you met?
Oh,
well we were in Panama and I was walking
down the street and I saw her and I was
like, I really want to do her
makeup as a makeup artist.
I saw her and to me she
was like the perfect model.
I went straight to her and I was like,
Ken,
either your makeup and let's like do
a photo shoot or something please.
We basically set up a team and
we made an amazing photo shoot.
Yeah, that was amazing.
So who starts for anyone?
I go, okay, perfect.
Never have I ever guns Kimmy.
Dot.
Dye Pink dipping. I don't know.
What does that mean? I'm sorry.
When you go swimming completely naked.
Oh my God.
It was like when on vacation with friends.
Oh, I don't remember. So many times
maybe if I lay my own pool,
maybe I would do it.
But like anywhere else I'm like, no. Uh,
never have I ever farted. Well, laughing
one, two, three,
I, I don't remember. Like I know
like if I would have done it,
I would've never forgotten because
I would have paid as myself so much.
So since I don't have any memories
of that, I'd probably not.
That's the kind of things that happens,
like not a one time thing, you know,
it happens.
So never have I ever wanted to be famous.
So I want to create like really good
work and I want to be like the best I
possibly can in my profession.
But I'm scared of people
getting too involved with me.
Like I still want to be able to go and
flip flops to the supermarket and no one
caring about that.
So,
and know me,
it's like years ago in like,
I'm working as a model and I
wanted to get to get famous more.
Cause I think I said to I and then of
course you know by the understanding and
with the years,
you know you're not like searching
for this kind of things no more,
but when you are very young
he won this kind of things.
Yes sir.
No people have the wrong idea
about modeling and makeup.
Ooh
Yes. Oh yes. Oh you want to go first.
Sometimes people think that makeup is
something that's superficial that has to
with vanity and it's not
true. For example, in my case,
makeup artistry is like painting,
drawing,
sculpting, et cetera. But
instead of having a blank canvas,
your canvas is a human being.
So you are creating a living and a moving
work of art and that takes a lot of
time and that takes a lot of effort.
But makeup can also
transform a person's life.
One time I had a client and either,
no, like she had, she had cancer.
When I finished doing her makeup,
she look in the mirror and she said,
today I don't feel sick.
That's powerful.
It can change the way a
person sees themselves.
That's why I believe that sometimes
people have a wrong idea of makeup.
I think, you know, like four
models mainly. We are also humans.
You know what I mean? Oh,
well we are human beings.
And for me starting modeling
was a way to escape. Uh,
also my family. We are
humans, you know? Okay.
So never have I ever been jealous.
A few.
Um,
oh,
oh you, you want to, you want to know
why it's not now, but when I met you,
so this is like a very dark
topic. When I met you, uh,
I used to suffer from,
from like self image issues and eating
disorders and I saw you and I was like,
I wish I were a skinny as her.
And that's what I was,
the only thing I wanted back then I only
wanted to be skinny and I lost a lot of
weight, a lot of weight. There
came a point where I basically,
I was eating too little, I was eating
too little and I thought that was okay.
And I was like sic row and it was the
skinniest person in the world and I was so
happy. And then I got sick. I
felt so bad because I was like,
I thought this was going to make me happy
and I thought that this was like the
ideal.
Then my body is rejecting this weight,
my buddy is rejecting this lifestyle
and this behavior and I analyze like my
priority should be my health no
matter what and I'm healthy now.
And I'm like, Oh my God, you look
so pretty. You look so full of life.
And I'm like still trying to accept it.
You know? It's not easy, but at least,
at least now I'm like, this is the
right thing. This is the right thing.
So yeah,
that's basically what happened.
And I'm so glad that I finally
could grow out of that.
Yeah, I'm glad. Yeah,
because you're shining,
you don't need to
to be less.
You'd be just to be you and a half has
no price. You know what I mean? Yeah.
I had exactly the same one. I was
very young, I was 15 and I was,
I was probably a seeking for attention
or I don't know what I was exactly
seeking for.
I had troubles with my mom and I try
with my father and my stepmother was
extremely controlling, manipulative
and all that. I was terrible.
I think what we all want all
to be so skinny and blah blah.
But I think we are trying to to,
I don't know,
there's a name motional problem. There
isn't a problem inside of us, you know,
and I'm, I'm happy that you
accept yourself the way you are.
I had to accept myself and when I
accepted I, everything was okay.
The next one,
yes or no,
I mess up a lot.
Okay.
Yes,
of course.
Yes.
And we learn about an hour messing up
basically from all what we are doing.
Yes. And we learn, we learn willow.
I feel that I take a
lot of risks in my life.
Like I do a lot of things that are very
risky and it's not always going to end
up how you want it to and it's
not always going to end up well.
Yeah,
I miss a ball.
So because I put myself in in really
dangerous situations, you know,
like I went to Panama like this,
you know,
I know that I invest a lot also in people.
I get emotionally invested a lot.
I get heartbroken,
but you know what I lived with,
I had to leave and live it to the fullest.
I live at 100% so yes,
I miss a lot,
but it's, my life is like really
full and I really love. Exactly.
You know what I mean? Exactly.
Oh my God. Yay for them.
That is so yes or know your partner
knows how truly amazing they are.
Yes or no.
That's
Si.
Yeah. I think, you know,
I feel that you know how amazing you
are because you've been through so much.
It doesn't matter how hard it is, you
always choose you. So you always see,
know how amazing you are
and how much you were worth.
And I really admire and respect
that of you because like in my case,
it took me forever to really choose me,
but for me too, it takes
me forever. You know,
it's not a mall little by little,
but um, yeah, I know that you,
you know, so, oh, how amazing
you are. You're very positive.
It's hard to find positive people.
Trust me.
No, and it was hard for me
to be like five years ago.
People wouldn't say that of me.
Like I used to be really,
really depressed and really
anxious. Yeah. And I,
it makes me really happy
that a person that,
that found me like later in the future
would see me this way because it means
that I truly have changed and that's
everything that I ever worked for.
I'm glad I met you.
Yeah,
me too.
What's up jubilee fam.
Thanks for watching that Canada episode
of season three is beginning and we got
some great ones for you this time.
Seriously. Our best episodes yet.
Mark my words,
we got more videos for you here.
You can also subscribe right there.
Keep it cool. Keep it awesome. Have Fun.
You are beautiful.
I'll see you guys around.